قالت مصادر للجزيره ان الجيش الجزائري قصف
بالمروحيات قافله تضم خاطفين ورهاء في
منشاه للغاز جنوب شرقي البلاد ما ادى الى
مقتل 35 رهينا و55
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
خاطفا
[موسيقى]
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش من زاويتين هل
كانت القوه الوسيله الامثل في التعامل مع
ازمه الرهائن المختطفين في
الجزائر وفي اي اتجاه ستاخذ هذه التطورات
المواقف الدوليه من العمليه الفرنسيه في
[موسيقى]
مالي اسعد الله اوقاتكم
تسارعت الاحداث في مجمع عين اميناس لانتاج
الغاز في الجزائر سيطره لمسلحي القاعده
على الموقع اوقعت مئات الرهائن بايديهم
فمحاوله للتفاوض والخروج الامن ثم هجوم من
الجيش الجزائري اوقع عددا من القتله
والجرحى بين الخاطفين والمختطفين
حادثه ستؤثر بلا شك في التطورات التي تجري
حاليا في مالي
المجاوره تبدد فرص التفاوض والت الكلمه
النهائيه الى المعالجه الامنيه وسط غموض
لف احداثا داميه متسارعه العشرات من
الرهائن وخطفوه يقعون بين قتيل وجريح بعد
ان تصدت نيران الجيش الجزائري لمحاوله
سيارات للخاطفين على متنها بعض الرهائن
مغادره مجمع عين اميناس الغازي اكدت
التقارير مصرع ابو البرا قائد كتيبه
الموقعون بالدم التي كانت ي طرت على
الموقع في وقت سابق لتتال بعد ذلك اخبار
عن تحرير اعداد متزايده من المحتجزين قدرت
بالمئات اغلبهم جزائريون وموظفون من
جنسيات مختلفه بعضها امريكي واوروبي
واسيوي انهى الهجوم الجزائري عمليا
محاولات ابو البراء لتفادي الاشتباك عندما
طالب القوات التي حاصرت الموقع بالتراجع
لافساح المجال لفرصه التفاوض بين الخاطفين
ودول المختطفين
ب مسعا لحثها على الضغط من اجل انهاء
العمليات العسكريه الفرنسيه في مالي مع
التلويح بقتل كل الرهائن في حال رفض مطلب
التفاوض بد للبعض ان الجزائر شرعت تدفع
ثمن الضوء الاخضر الذي منحته للمقاتلات
الفرنسيه كي تعبر الاجواء الجزائريه وهي
في طريقها لقصف معاقل المسلحين الاسلاميين
في شمال ووسط مالي وسط تساؤلات حول مدى
تحسب النظام الجزائري لتداعيات قراره
واستعداده لردود الفعل المحتمله التي يمكن
لتنظيم القاعده في المغرب الاسلامي ان
يقدم عليها ردا على الهجمات التي تستهدفه
وفي انتظار ان تتكشف جوانب اكثر من صوره
الاحداث التي وصفها الرئيس الفرنسي
فرونسوا اولاند نفسه بالغامدي بقيت اسئله
محيره عالقه مدارها السهوله التي استطاع
بها المسلحون السيطره على موقع يفترض به
ان يكون عالي التحصين ومدى الامكانيات
التي كانت متاحه لتفادي التدخل العسكري
العنيف خاصه بعد ان افرج المختطفون عن
النسوه اللوات كن محتجزات بين بقيه
الرهائن نقاط استفهام الواضح في غموضها
ربما ان شن الحرب على اتباع القاعده في
مالي لا يعني بالضروره القدره على التحكم
باتساع رقعتها وبكيف التي ستنتهي بها
ومعنا في هذه الحلقه من العاصمه الماليه
باماكو سمايلو بوبي مايجا وزير خارجيه
جمهوريه مالي السابق مدير مرصد دول الساحل
والصحراء للدراسات من لندن محمد العربي
زيتوت احد مؤسسي حركه رشاد الجزائريه
المعارضه ومن الجزائر عبر الهاتف الدكتور
احمد عظيمي استاذ العلوم السياسيه
والاعلام بجامعه الجزائر اهلا بضيوفنا
جميعا نبدا من الجزائر الدكتور احمد عظيمي
هناك الان حيره واستياء في عواصم عديده
فيما يتعلق
بعمليه العمليه العسكريه في في حادثه الرئ
هل كان اللجوء الى القوه خيارا لا مفر منه
بالنسبه
للجزائر هو الوضع كان كالتالي ان مجموعه
ارهابيه استولت على قاعده بتروليه و
احتجزت مجموعه من الجزائريين ومن
الاجانب المطالب كانت واضحه وهو توفير
سيارات رباعيه الدفه وممر امن بمعنى انه
لو تسمح لهم بالذهاب
هذا معناه انهم سياخذ الاجانب كرهائن
لا ندري ماذا سيفعلون بهم فيما
بعد يفاوضون بهم يقتلونهم لا ندري كان هذا
حل والحل الثاني هو ان يكون هناك محاوله
لتحرير الرهائن باستعمال القوه الجيش
الجزائري له تجربه في مجال معالجه مثل هذه
القضايا له تجربه طويله
و حسب الاخبار لانه الان لا يوجد اي خبر
ما عدا بعض بيان مقتض جدا من وكاله
الانباء الجزائريه لا توجد اخبار لا ندري
حقيقه ما يقع اخبار تتناولها وكالات
الانباء بعض الهاتف الى اخره وبالتالي
يقال ان الجزائر الجيش الجزائري فتل
التدخل
ولا شك ان هذا التدخل
سحقق ننتيجه باقل الاضرار لانه لم يكن
هناك حل اخر هذا في راي نعم قبل ذلك
كانت
المسؤولين الفرنسيين على لسان وزير الدفاع
السيد لودري الفرنسي يقول بان لدينا ثقه
كامله في قدره السلطات الجزائريه على حل
هذا المشكل وهنا نسال السيد سميل بوبي ماا
عما اذا كان
بتقديره هذا
اللجوء للقوه من قبل السلطات الجزائريه
كان موفقا
انا
في بعد اذنك سيد عظيمي السؤال موجه للسيد
مايجا في
بماكو
نعم لا شك ان طريقه ال عمل وطريقه حل هذه
الازمه في الواقع لم تترك خيارا امام
السلطات الجزائريه الى محاوله وقف هذه
العمليه والحؤول دون وصول المختطفين الى
هدفهم تعرفون انه في العام 2003 قام نفس
التنظيم باختطاف مجموعه من الرهائن
الغربيين وقطعوا معهم الحدود مع مالي
وطبعا خلال هذه الازمه شهدنا
مفاوضات طلبوا فيها مبلغا من حوالي 5
ملايين يورو ومنذ العام 2003 او ابتداء من
هذا التاريخ رايتم طبعا اكثر من 40 عمليه
اختطاف في هذه المنطقه كلها ترجمت لاحقا
باستثناء حالتين اثنتين بدفع لمبلغ من
المال اذا ادت في نهايه المطاف الى زياده
قدره هذه القوه او هذه التنظيمات
الارهابيه في المنطقه وفي ضوء السياق الذي
تجري فيه الامور في ضوء الظروف وطبيعه
المطالبات من قبل هذا التنظيم الذي لا
يمكن ان يقبل به باي شكل من الاشكال من
قبل الدوله الجزائريه اعتبر ان ما من
طريقه اخرى تحول دون وصولهم الى اهدافهم
اي هدفهم يكون باخذ هؤلاء رهاء ولا نعرف
طبعا ما يكون مصيرهم بعد ذلك اما ربما
قتلهم او حتى الاستفاده منهم كمصدر
للايرادات وهذا يعني انهم سوف يملكون قوى
اضافيه لزعزع الاستقرار في المنطقه مع
ذلك مع ذلك كانت
السلطات الجزائريه مستعده لحوار سيد عربي
زيتوت مستعده للحوار لكن كانت لديها خشيه
من على سلامه الرهائن وهذا امر لم يكن
بامكان الجزائر ان تتسامح فيه برايك مره
اخرى خيار القوه كان خيارا اجباريا
للسلطات في
الجزائر تحياتي لك والمشاهدين الكرام ولا
انا استمعت لوزير الداخليه مباشره وهو
يقول ليس امام الخاطفين اي خيار اخر الا
الاستسلام او سنتدخل عسكريا هذا هو
وبالتالي هم لم يقولوا انهم سيتفاوض ولكن
الدفاع والقول انه لم يكن هناك خيار اخر
في الحقيقه هذا لا يسنده منطق ولا عقل اول
شيء من تسبب في هذه الحادثه في اكثر من 21
سنه منذ ان دخلت الجزائر من 92 منذ انقلاب
92 ومنذ ان دخلت الجزائر في حرب النظام ضد
هذه المجموعات او المجموعات ضد هذه النظام
سميها ما شئت لم تتعرض هذه المجموعات سواء
المخترقه منها او الصحيحه او المصطنعه لم
تتعرض للغاز والبترول الجزائري وصناعه
النفطيه في الجنوب وهي مصدر 99% من مداخل
الجزائر اذا هؤلاء وقد قالوها صراحه احد
الخاطفين قال صراحه باننا هذا رد فعل على
تورط الجزائر ومساندتها لفرنسا في في هذه
الحرب في مالي الامر الثاني كيف نسمح
لانفسنا ان نتورط مع مستعمر الامس الذي لم
يعترف ولمده 130 سنه بوجود الجزائر كيف
نسمح له ان نتورط مع الامر الثالث كيف
نسمح لهذه الطائرات التي كانت تقمع يوما
ما ثوار الجزائريين ان تمر عبر الاجواء
وتقمع اخرين وهم اخواننا واشقائه بل وفيهم
ابناؤنا هؤلاء القبائل العربيه الترجيه هي
قبائل موزعه على عده دول وهذه وهم حتى
منهم الجزائريين ثم كيف نسمح ان يتم
التلاعب وناتي بحرب على الصحراء الجزائريه
وهي الصحراء ايضا التي كانت من مطامع
فرنسا وقد استمرت الثوره الجزائريه ثلاث
سنوات لكي تبقى لكي تكون الصحراء فرنسيه
سيد زيتوت يعني بعد اذنك
يعني بعد اذنك هذا هذا هذا جر للنقاش في
بعد الجزائري الفرنسي المثقل بالتاريخ لكن
فيما يتعلق بهذه العمليه تحديدا في هذه
العمليه تحديدا السلطات
الجزائريه اولا اعداد الرهائن لم تكن
واضحه اعداد الخاطفين لم تكن واضحه ال
العمليه ليس واضحا على الاقل حتى حتى
اعداد هذا البرنامج برايك ان ان تختار
السلطات
الجزائريه هجوم بالمروحيات وقصف لطابور
كان سيذهب بال الرهائن لاماكن ربما غير
معلومه لم يكن هناك من خيار اخر امام
السلطات في هذا الموضوع
تحديدا منطقه عيننا ميناس تبعد باكثر من
1000 مر على حدود مالي بمعنى السؤال اولا
كيف وصل هؤلاء الى المنطقه اساسا ثم كيف
يستطيعون ان يذهبوا الى مالي في 1000 كتر
من الصحراء هناك وهناك الوجود الفرنسي
والامريكي والجزائري والبريطاني وتقريبا
كل العالم الان يتواجد في المنطقه كيف
سيسمح لهم بالذهاب الى هناك ثم كيف تبدا
وتقول مباشره لن اتفاوض اما الاستسلام
واما سنقتل بالرغم ان هؤلاء الخاطفين وانا
طبعا ادين العمليه ولكن هؤلاء الخاطفين لم
يقوموا مثلا بقتل الرهائن حتى تقول ان
هؤلاء بداوا يقتلون في الرهائن وبالتالي
لم يكن لاخيار كانت لديك مجموعه من
الخيارات ثم ان الدول حتى القوى العظمى
تاخذ في الغالب تاخذ وقت اطول وتحاول ان
تعطل الخاطفين وتحاول وكانها تناور معهم
لكي تربح من الوقت لكي تخطط للعمليه لكي
تستخدم كل طاقاتها لكي تستخدم كل ما اوتيت
وليس هكذا تدخل بالطائرات نقتل الجميع
نقتل الابرياء والخاطفين نقت نقصف الغاز
نقصف قواعدنا اقتصادنا ثم هذه اهانه امام
العالم خاصه لدوله كان يقال لنا انها
مدرسه نتعلم منها كثير من الغربيين كان
يقولون ان الجزائر والجيش الجزائري قوي
وهو مدرسنا تعلم منه استمعنا لهولاند قبل
قليل بغض النظر عن مدى ارتباط هذه العمليه
بما يجري في مالي السؤال ربما الاهم الان
في الايام المقبله هو تاثير ما جرى على
مجريات الامور فيما يجري في مالي حاليا
تحديدا لنا عوده الى هذا الموضوع بعد فاصل
قصير نرجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نناقش فيها عيات ازمه الرهائن
المخطوفين في الجزائر وتاثيرها على
العمليه الفرنسيه الجاريه حاليا في مالي
السيد سمايلو بوبي مايجا في في
باماكو وزير الدفاع الفرنسي السابق جيرار
لونجي قال بان هذه العمليه في الجزائر لا
علاقه لها بالمره بما يجري في مالي لانها
عمليه من هذا النوع يفترض انها تم الاعداد
لها قبل فتره وب
ترتيبات اخذت وقت هل تعتقد فعلا بهذا
السيناريو اذا كان تم من رابط بين
العمليتين اقول انهم الاشخاص
فكما ترون المختطفون هم من تنظيم مختار
بالمختار ونتذكر جميعا ان هذا الشخص سوف
يحاكم في الجزائر بعد ايام اربع
وهذه المحاكمه تر بما قام به في اطار
العمليات الارهابيه اذا الرابط موجود لانه
خطط كذلك لعمليه من هذا النوع وقادها
بنجاح نسبي طبعا وهذا يتطلب اكثر من يومين
او ثلاث بالتالي اعتقد ان هذه العمليه نعم
خطط لها منذ وقت طويل ولكن في الوقت عينه
تستهدف ما يجري نربط هنا مع الاحداث التي
تجري في مالي اي التاثير في الراي العام
من الناحيه النفسيه وبشكل كبير ايضا على
الراي العام في مالي وفي المنطقه باكملها
بما يضعف من عزيمه القوات وهذا الاطار
وهذه العمليه اي في المنطقه الافريقيه
باكملها وفي الواقع لا اعتقد ان هذه هذا
التداعي المباشر لعلهم انتهزو فرصه لكي
يتحركوا وتمكنوا في الوقت عينه من
الاستفاده من هذا الصدى الاعلامي وهذه
الضجه الاعلاميه لان العمليه غطت بشكل
كبير في وسائل الاعلام ولكن طبعا اكرر
انها خطط لها منذ وقت طويل واعتبرت تبريرا
او انتهزت ما يجري في مالي كتبرير ولكن
طبعا كان خلفها الارهابيون المعروفون وهل
تعتقد بان معالجه السلطات الجزائريه لقضيه
الرهان بهذا الشكل
سيؤجج القتال على الجبهه في مالي بشكل الي
تقريبا
نعم طبعا في مالي وكما قلت قبل
قليل ان الطريقه او العقيده الجزائريه تكم
في عدم التفاوض مع الخاطفين وهذه الطريقه
الصحيحه لان من ذلك ان يشجعهم طبعا على
متابعه عمليتهم اذكر مره اخرى انظم عينه
كان قد اختطف 32 سائحا اوروبيا في العام
2003 ومنذ تلك الحقبه لم يكف هؤلاء عن
تحركاتهم ولم يكفوا ايضا عن تعزيز قواتهم
الماليه وتجهيزاتهم الان بالنسبه
للتداعيات على العمليه في مالي بكل بساطه
ران هذه المنطقه الواسعه من ليبيا او
الحدود المصريه الليبيه وصولا الى حدود
مالي مع موريتانيا اذا في هذه الرقعه
تعرفون ان الوضع معقدا جدا ولا سما على
مستوى الامن والاستقرار وربما يستدعي ذلك
جهودا اكثر ومن قبل اطراف متعدده لكي
نواجه هذا التهديد التهديد الارهابي في
المنطقه ولكن سيد ماي الا تعتقد بان فرنسا
ربما في ضوء ما جرى في موضوع الرهائن قد
تعيد حساباتها فيما يتعلق ب اسلوب تعاملها
مع الوضع في مالي
الان
لا اعتقد ان الفرنسيين سوف يعيدون
حساباتهم تعرفون ان فرنسا اتت الى مالي
بطلب من الدوله الماليه واذا كانت سوف
تعيد حساباتها فسيكون ذلك بتعزيز لوجودها
وتعزيز لعملياتها لسوء الحظ فان الطريقه
التي تجري فيها العمليات اظهرت لنا من دون
ادنى شك ان هذه القدرات لم تكن كافيه
قدراتنا نحن كدوله ماليه بالتالي اعتبر
انه لا بد من ان ننتهز هذه الفرصه لكي
نحاول اعطاء اكبر زخم وضرب ه هذه
التنظيمات باكبر شكل ممكن وان نتحاور بخط
موازن مع اولئك الذين يعتبرون جاهزين
للحديث معنا في اطار السلامه وفي اطار
المشاكل المختلفه نعم دكتور احمد عظيمي
بعض المقاتلين في مالي معروف انهم
جزائريون حتى ان رئيس الكتيبه التي سيطرت
على
ديبالي شمال باماكو يدعى بوزيد وهو من
قاده تنظيم القاعده في بلاد المغرب
الاسلامي هل تعتقد بان هؤلاء الجزائريين
تحديدا ربما سيصبحون اكثر شراسه في القتال
في مالي في ضوء ما حدث لرفاقهم بين قوسين
او اخوانهم في الجزائر في عمليه الرهائن
لا هو الوضع الوضع في مالي الان اصبح معقد
كثيرا في مالي في شمال مالي كان هناك حل
وكان هناك اتفاق على ان يكون حوار لكن لا
ا لماذا كان هناك ممكن توجيه
لمجموعات معينه لاحتلال كونه وهذا اعطى
ذريعه لفرنسا لتتدخل عسكريا وكذا وبالتالي
ان ما يقع اليوم في
الجزائر العمليه التي وقعت وانتم سبق لاحد
المتدخلون ان قال ان هذا لم يقع حتى في
حتى في اثناء الارهاب يعني في عز الارهاب
لم
تتعرض القواعد البتروليه ل اي هجوم من طرف
المجموعات الارهابيه وهي الان تتعرض لهذا
وهذا نتيجه التدخل الفرنسي نحن من عده
اشهر نتكلم ونقول ان اي تدخل عسكريي في
مالي سيزم الازمه لانه لم يحدث في السابق
ابدا ان ابد التدخل العسكري الاجنبي ل لحل
اي مشكله في الصومال الجيش الامريكي فيرو
هربه في العراق دمروه وسموه الى ثلاث
دويلات وفروا من هناك في افغانستان هم
يفرون من هناك لذلك قلنا اكثر من مره انه
لا يجب ان يكون هناك تدخل عسكري ثم اليوم
لما تقنب تقنب ماذا تضرب ماذا لا توجد لا
توجد منشات قاعديه ان المجموعات الارهابيه
الان انسحبت اختبات هي مجموعات قليله جدا
ومدربه على حرب العصابات وبالتالي لا يمكن
ان نضربها بالطيران لا يمكن الذباب
بالمدفعيه فرنسا ترتكب خطا كبير جدا في حق
الشعب وفي حق الشعب الجزائري ونحن اليوم
ندفع ثمن هذا وانا سبق تدخلت في العديد من
وسائل الاعلام وقلت ان المستهدف من التدخل
عسكري في شمال المي هو جنوب الجزائر وها
هو جنوب الجزائر يتعرض لبدايات حرب قد
تدوم طوي لا ندري ماذا سيقع مستقبلا لذلك
ان اكبر خطا ركبته فرنسا هو تدخلها
فيي ولكن مع ذلك مع ذلك سيد احمد العظمي
مع ذلك يون الى هذه المنطقه مع ذلك دكتور
هناك وجهه نظر مثلا كالتي عبر عنها روماني
روماني برودي مبعوث الامم المتحده للساحل
قال بان التدخل الفرنسي وهنا اسال السيد
محمد العربي زيتوت ان التدخل الفرنسي لم
يكن هناك مفر منه لان هذه المنطقه كانت
ستصبح منطقه حره بالضبط هي منطقه حره
ارهابيه في قلب
افريقيا فرودي ذاته قبل شهر قال العكس
تماما ا منذ سنوات ونحن نقول في حركه رشاد
ان تضخيم الخطر الارهابي من طرف الصحافه
القريبه من المخابرات الجزائريه والتي في
الغالب تعبر عن لسانها في القضايا الامنيه
هذا خطر على الجزائر وعلى وحدتها وعلى
صحرائها وخاصه ونحن نعلم ان القوه الكبرى
تتربص بنا وتتربص ب ثرواتنا وخاصه ان
النظام ضعيف وغير شرعي وغير شعبي ولا يحظى
ب تلك القوه الشعبيه وبالتالي القوه
الخارجيه تستطيع ان تبتزه منذ سنوات وانا
هنا فقط اشير ربما لبعضها ذكرنا ذلك في
حركه رشاد وذكرت ذلك انا عده مرات هذا
الاشكال كما تفضل المتحدث السابق نحن ندفع
الثمن تدخل الفرنسي الفرنسيين لن يخسروا
شيء نحن ندفع ثمن هذا التدخل الدليل اليوم
ما يحدث في ع عنا ميناس ثم الشيء الاخر
بالنسبه ل حتى هذا مختار بالمختار تدور
حوله شكوك كثيره كانت صحافه الج الجزائريه
تحدثت عنه وكما قلت هي قريبه من المخابرات
تحدثت عنه وقالت انه سيقود صحوه وسيحب
القاعده اذا من هو مختار بالمختار في
الحقيقه هناك كثير من التساؤل ربما مرتبط
ببعض الجهات او الاجهزه داخل الجزائر
المشكله في الجزائر ان ليس هناك نظام براس
واحد وانما هناك اجنحه في الغالب ما تكون
متشاكسين دفع ثمن صراعها وصدام وايضا
السياسه اساسيه ومركز السماح للمستعمر
الامس بالمجيء الى جوارنا والدخول قول له
ونحن الذي اعترضنا على ذلك في ليبيا لماذا
اعترضنا على تواجد الش الدولي في ليبيا
عندما كان القذافي يذبح شعبه ونقبل الان
ان تاتي فرنسا وتذبح الماليين وتقصف
الماليين ونحن ندفع الثمن في الصحراء
الجزائريه وفي الشريان الحيوي للبلاد
الغاز والبترول ومنه تاتي
99% هناك شعور بمراره كبيره وبغضب كبير
لدى الجزائريين من ان نظام الحكم لا يعرف
كيف يدير شؤون الدوله ومن ان هذا يدفع بنا
الى التضحيه بمصالحنا القوميه وبمصالح
وبشعور وبثور تنا وباخلاص وبكثير من
الاشياء للاسف ندفع ثمنها لمن لصالح
المستعمر بالامس هذه حقيقه تعتبر كارثه
وتعتبر ضربه كبيره للشعور القومي
لاخلاقيات الشعب الجزائري خاصه ونحن نقول
اننا نرفض التدخل الدولي شكرا لك شكرا لك
من لندن محمد العربي زيد توت احد مؤسسي
حركه رشاد الجزائريه المعارضه شكرا لضيفنا
ايضا من العاصمه الماليه بمكو سميو بوبي
مايجا وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا من الجزائر كان
معنا عبر الهاتف الدكتور احمد عظيمي استاذ
العلوم السياسيه بجامعه الجزاء بهذا نصل
الى نهايه هذه الحلقه دمتم في رعايه الله
والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ه